welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and one division is days away from
launching marvel's multiverse saga on
disney plus
and finally telling us more than we are
an unusual couple you know
we are an unusual couple we are an
unusual couple
this is gonna be a no spoiler review of
the major takeaways among the first
reactions to episodes one two and three
and since this marvel story is disguised
as a love letter to tv land with
alternate genre tropes that weren't
initially intended to kick
off this phase of superhero movies and
series i thought it would help for
prospective viewers to know what you're
getting into now again
no spoilers here though i will be do
some theorizing and speculating that's
gonna echo the marvel comics story lines
and characters that have been long
speculated to appear in this show so if
you don't want to know anything
maybe don't go on social media take
personal responsibility for yourself
anyway take away one and i consider this
to be the big question for you die hard
marvel fans
one division keeps its mysteries a
mystery
at first if you consider the nine
episode season of one division in three
acts
these first three episodes are kind of
act one and they really serve to set up
the visual rules of this world
but really just hint at the dark truths
underneath so at this stage
we don't really know anything collider
stephen weintraub agrees saying one two
and three
only give you a hint to what is really
going on paul bettany has said that the
final three episodes 789 will be the
turn
where all is revealed and the series
moves on from rapid progression through
the sitcoms of the decades
to more of a sober avenger style
conflict and to really get your purple
pieces moving betany also dropped
this infinity gem in his interview with
black girl nerds there's stuff that i
can't talk to you about is gonna be
a surprise for everybody i get to work
with an actor that i've been wanting to
work with
for forever is just
unbelievable we have some real uh
fireworks together hopefully it's
mephisto i
need this win but before we continue i
want to thank our friends
keeps for sponsoring this episode losing
your hair can be a bummer folks
especially if it's involuntary and not
because of your quest to become more
aerodynamic two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35
with keeps it is easier and more
affordable to get treatment for your
hair loss and help you keep the hair
that you have keeps offers generic
versions of the only two fda approved
hair loss products out there
but at half the cost of your local
pharmacy
what a deal and you don't have to go to
the doctor's office you can do it all
from the comfort of your own home you
just meet with a doctor online
and they ship the treatment right to you
every three months so you don't have to
wait in line at the pharmacy
find out why keeps has more five star
reviews than any of its competitors and
nearly 100 000 men trust keeps for their
hair loss prevention medication so if
you're noticing that you're losing your
hair
do something about it folks for a
limited time go to keeps.com
new rockstars or click the link in the
description to receive
50 off your first order so in these
first three episodes the series is
playing things very close to the best
it's all very coy they're more about
having fun
and living in and enjoying the classic
sitcom tributes but
there is a sense that something is very
wrong with this world of west
view bringing us to take away two sitcom
gags
really mask horror words like funny and
clever are being used to describe the
sitcom
performances by elizabeth olsen paul
bettany catherine hahn and tiana paris
but the word creepy stands out as the
one telling us what's really going on
here
actually funny clever and creepy were
the words of our buddy hector navarro
referencing the various glitches in the
matrix hinting at the
greater conspiracy behind westview
whatever it is
it's like when you watch movies like get
out like nothing's really creepier than
being trapped in a situation where
everyone seems to be brainwashed unaware
of how effed up
everything actually is and you can see
this in the clips that have been
released so far
like when wanda envisioned laugh it up
over a bump in the night
while no one seems to take seriously
what the hell that violent bump was
or when they have a date circled on
their calendar well don't tell me you
have forgotten this
forgotten a wonder i'm incapable of
forgetfulness i remember everything
that's not an exaggeration in fact i'm
incapable of exaggeration
well then tell me what's so important
about today's date
what was the question again oh wow
perhaps you've forgotten yourself
hey heavens no i've been so looking
forward to it
with no earthly idea what this date
means
memory loss isn't fun and when memory
loss doesn't bother anyone it's
really not fun and actually feels a bit
more like a cult that might be fun to
you but to everyone else
you're going to want to get out get out
take away three
one division opens doors in the mcu
doors that cannot be closed hector also
said that it's taking the mcu places it
has never
gone before and there is no going back
it also hinted that the series is taking
inspiration from certain iconic scarlet
witch and vision storylines in the
comics it's really too soon to say which
ones but just to remind you of the
possible comic influences of course
house of m in which a grief-stricken
wanda maximoff uses her reality warping
powers to reset all of
reality again and again with projections
of her two children until she eventually
declares
no more mutants and mutants are erased
from existence
that amazon de nepri wine bottle or
maybe house of misery house of contempt
could be a nod to house of m there's
also the tom
king vision series that depicts vision
as the head of a nuclear family
and then there's the 80s west coast
avengers storyline that shows wanda in
vision with kids in a plot that involves
mephisto trying to drain her over chaos
magic
really the thing is one of vision's
format signals the launch of marvel's
multiverse saga
and once it's established that wanda can
warp reality like this
you can't really close that pandora's
box every marvel installment that comes
after this
is gonna exist within this vast
multiverse you could argue
every marvel movie already has but this
one's gonna show us what that looks like
nikki novak of vandango echoed this
saying that although we only get a
glimpse so far that all isn't right in
west view
marvel left the door open to the multi
ways it can play out and that the magic
show scene
was just that so yeah as we predicted
this scene with vision and wanda
performing a magic act at the town
talent show is a pivotal moment that's
gonna signal to
us and to the couple that these two have
a greater power over that magic than
their sitcom selves thought they should
but is wandavision good look it is early
most of what you see out there on social
media is going to be positive and
supportive
everyone's praising the stylistic
performances and keeping an open mind
about the mysteries in the story but i
think one thing
mcu fans should prepare for is that this
series might not
at first feel like it was made for you
so
takeaway 4 weird is good the truth is
folks that not every avenger is best
served with the same prototypical
workshop montage stumbling power test
and villain with mirrored ambitions
characters like wanda maximoff are
beloved in the comics precisely for the
way their minds work
which is why this series is so weird
with such a different format than what
we've come to expect from the mcu
breaking the mold is the only way to
tell wanda's story effectively and
properly
our friend dorian parks felt this way
too he called the series weird as
hell in a good way let's hope hell ends
up being a choice word
and over at fandom eric goldman agreed
saying one division is a
weird way to return to the mcu it wasn't
meant to kick it off after all
and it will take some adjustment for
typical fans but to those who just felt
all superhero stories can feel the same
here is big proof otherwise delightfully
trippy and
intriguing now a reminder folks that we
are going to be covering one division
with same day after shows every friday
inside marvel followed by my shot by
shot easter egg breakdowns the next day
you can celebrate by checking out our
new latest obsession shirt
an unusual couple it's got hidden easter
eggs
among visions floating consciousness
revealed via augmented reality
it is so cool i didn't know shirts could
do that and those who get this shirt can
actually write in custom shout outs that
will appear on screen
in our inside marvel after show episodes
meanwhile epic hero shop has launched
their own companion shirt
if you care about keeping this unusual
couple together which you should
and that one has a secret ar component
too ooh and finally reminder that epic
hero shop
is giving away 10 playstation 5s you
enter by subscribing to their youtube
channel epic hero labs it's
real weird interesting not sure what's
going on there and then you just fill
out the form that you find at
epicheroshop.com
giveaway there's also a bunch of ways to
get more entries into the giveaway right
there so
check it out and as always follow me at
eaboss on instagram and twitter got a
lot of fun darla photos i'm putting up
there and follow new rockstars subscribe
to new rockstars here on youtube thank
you for watching
i love you i feel like we're part of an
unusual couple
[Music]
you